tiens vous avez vu ce que vont pouvoir
faire les bureaux de tabac juste petite
les bureaux de tabac vont pouvoir
maintenant vendre des munitions de
chasse alors ça n' rien à voir avec les
P je dis en même temps que ces
cigarettes dans les bureaux de tabac
regardez c'est un truc de fou ça c'est
catastrophique au côté des cartouches de
cigarettes pourrait bientôt figurer les
cartouches de fusil de chasse ben moi je
trouve que c'est une très bonne idée
parce que on trouve de moins en moins de
magasins spécialisés c'est peut-être une
opportunité pour nous de développer nos
commerces moi sur le principe je me dis
que c'est plutôt une bonne chose par
rapport à ma cette nouvelle mesure
permettrait aux 24000 buralistes de
France de compenser la baisse des ventes
de cigarettes le ministère de
l'Intérieur a confirmé que le projet
devrait prendre effet à partir du 1er
janvier
2024 alors oui je suis totalement contre
et j'ai toujours défendu les chasseurs
qui vous a demandé votre
avis c'est totalement délirant alors
certes les buralistes vont devoir passer
un examen mais un examen en 2 jours
avoir une certification et les chasseurs
qui achèteront devront montrer leur
permis de chasse mais ça va faire comme
le tabac pour les mineurs personne va
leur demander et on va avoir une vente
de munition pour la chasse en vente
libre moi je trouve ça délirant c'est la
France ça je suis d'accord avec lui et
par ailleurs les les les buralistes sont
souvent braqués moi je pense que ça peut
augmenter aussi le risque de braquage
supplémentairire avec des gens qui
pourraient potentiellement partir avec
un Boutin qui sont qui est qui est des
munition
[Musique]
beaucoup j'qu ce que dit
Valérie qu' ton petit
navire
c'est vrai pour des raisons de sécurité
c'est de la folie parce que les
armeriers sont vraiment beaucoup plus
sécurisés en parlant de P vous étiez
président du jury de Mister Picardy mis
nor on va revenir sur son incroyable
weekend regardez Daniel de
fou
mis le numéro 2 Antoine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ber
vous avez
vu vous avez vu qu'elle a sorti sa plus
belle tenue pour
l'occasion pareil que la C c'est celle
celleelle la lâche pas celle la sort que
pour les grandes occasions je vous le
dis c'est c'est un truc de fou bah bravo
Daniel en tout cas faittoi plaisir je
vais dire j'en doute pas j'espère que tu
as pu
conclure on a des nouvelles de Gérard
pardieu merci excusez-moi de vous
déranger oui bonsoir non je j'écouté
attentiv important tu écoute ce qui se
passe dans l'équipe c'est très bien TR
très bien bah oui de Part Dieu c'est
c'est la Une de closur et puis aussi de
France dimanche cette semaine où on le
voit effectivement à l'aéroport de
Lisbonne en fauteuil roulant donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe que lui
arrive-t-il il est effectivement très
affaibli en ce moment il est très voilà
contrarié par les différentes plaintes
pour pour harcèlement et agression
sexuelle qui sont qui le visent depuis
plusieurs mois et du coup il a décidé
d'aller s'abriter de de de de faire prof
fil pas au Portugal où il a élu domicile
pendant quelques semaines afin de ne
plus subir la pression de de de de toute
cette polémique alors euh g ce qui
inquiète ces proches c'est que ça fait
je crois 75 jours qu'il donneent plus de
nouvell il devait jouer au théâtre avec
Pierre Richard me semble-t-il il n'a pas
joué donc il s'est il devait aller aussi
à festival il Ilou il arrêté tous ses
projets donc voilà il était à l'aéroport
de Lisbonne en fauteuil roulant avec
donc une aide à domicile qui le pousse
donc c'est c'est inquiétant alors
qu'est-ce que ça signifie un sur son
état de santé deux sur moralement son
affaiblissement ou pas voilà c'est c'est
des images qui sont inquiétante par
rapport à Gérard de Parieu quand même il
faut savoir que Stéphane depdieu a eu
quand même un quintuple pontage il y a
quelques Gérard pardon a eu un
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Quint qu sans déconner Stéphane de pardu
mais c'est extraordinaire non mais c'est
une cadar bon il a eu un quintuple
pontage lui et Stéphane ont eu un
quintuple pontage il y a quelques années
qu'il a aussi également une greffe du
foie parce qu'il a eu un cancer du foie
donc ce sont quand même des choses qui
l'ont affaibli qui l'ont affaibli et du
coup aujourd'hui ça plus le fait que le
moral ne va pas à cause des des plaintes
bah c'est pas c'est pas grosse d'c pour
lui en ce moment ouais c'est non mais
c'est vrai que et donc voilà donc on on
est inquiet pour pour Gérard de pardieu
forcément en 6 de non mais même ses amis
he que ça soit neuve et cetera ils
essayent de le joindre il ne répond plus
du tout au téléphone donc tout le monde
est un peu inquiet la seule qui a encore
un peu des nouvelles c'est sa fille
Julie qu'il voit de de temps en temps
mais mais pour l'instant il est terré au
Portugal et il a pas l'intention de de
revenir il a pe avoir Bernard clavier
peut-être
berardavier non mais en plus çaez dur
pour lui parce que il est blacklisté par
par par les producteur plus personne
veul ve lui donner ve lui donner un rôle
les actrices ne veulent plus jouer j
avec lui donc c'est c'est un peu pour
lui très difficile à vivre d'accord oui
je vous dire c'est coupé du monde du
coup c'est vraiment inquiétant et
faut-il s'inquiéter je sais mais faut-il
s'inquiéter oui vraiment indépendamment
des affaires judiciaires lourdes bien
sûr mais il y a une vraie raison de
s'inquiéter pour lui quand on voit ses
photos et son état aujourd'hui quoi
alors il y a une enquête en cours
actuellement Gill ça en est où Ben pour
le moment il y a une enquête donc pour
viol et harcèlement sexuel avec la jeune
actrice Charlotte depuis 2018 et pour le
moment il y a pas de grandes avancées
judiciaires il faut bien le dire Cyril
ça fait partie de ces ces affaires pour
lesquelles il y a un fort retentissement
médiatique et après il y a le temps de
l'enquête et ça disparaît totalement de
nos radars alors on rappelle qu'il
conteste les accusations bien entendu
fermement totalement il avait fait sa
tribune au Figaro pour dire non je n'ai
rien fait je n'ai jamais agressé aucune
femme voilà il y avait eu cette plainte
plus le la plainte dans un premier temps
avait été classé sans suite en 2018
parce que le le à l'époque on estimait
qu' qui avait pas assez de fait
concordant et ça a été repris en 2020
parce qu'elle s'est porté Charlotte
Arnou s'est porté parti civil et du coup
à ce moment-là le juge d'instruction a
estimé qu'il y avait assez de fait et
notamment le des des des des des des
circonstances aggravantes parce que elle
était faible elle était anorexique pour
entamer une enquête alors il a eu dans
le passé un cancert il a même dû avoir
une greffe de foin Gérard oui voilà donc
c'est vrai que voilà pathologie très
lourde hein voilà il est diminué
aujourd'hui ça c'est indéniable c'est un
un homme diminué alors c'est vrai que
c'est il est pas obligé d'être en France
du coup puisqueil y a une enquête sur
lui non non il y a pas d'interdiction il
est du moment qu'il donne au juge c'est
coordonné son adresse il est établi il
est souvent au Portugal et voilà il a le
Portugal et puis son hôtel particulier
parisien aussi voilà il a deux domicile
et c'est vrai que fille il va il va
régulièrement chez sa fille c'est la
seule avec qui il discute encore et qui
prend soin de lui régulièrement très
bien merci myiam d'autres choses euh si
comme vous voulez moi je peux vous
parler de Kenny West je peux vous parler
de plein de trucs Ken West
bah Kenny West et il a fait le buzz
aujourd'hui parce que il est parti à
Dubaï présenter Duba à Dubaï Duba du il
il a pris quoi il a il a bu quoi là-bas
mjito à Dubaï il est parti à Dubaï il
est a-t-il mangé des
vagitas à Dubaï à Dubaï parce qu'il a
présenté il a présenté l'extrait an extr
de son dernier album voltour et
là-dedans il a des paroles très limites
voire antisémit et et du coup ça fait un
bu pas surtout qu'à cette fête il y
avait également Chris Bron qui est pas
réputé pour être un garçon très
sympathique donc ça fait le éta tous à
Dubaï à Dubaï non c'est vra en gros il a
dit je suis pas antisémite parce que je
fais l'amour avec une juive
ou je viens je cite les termes de
chanson c'est je viens de baiser une
[__] juive
c'est plusavais peur
de vient tout àprès bien
fait cont B toi tu d
totalant l'autre BIM non mais ça y est
elle part en cacahuè tot compr pouroi ça
bien sûr tu as raison merci tu restes
journaliste avant tout Oui c'est
ça qu que qu tu sais même pas ce que
c'est KIS je crois que c'est un vendeur
de sushi donc de quoi tu par tu mais il
a été taxé d'antisémitisme plein de fois
il avait eu des propos extrêmement
problématiques il avait dit que Hitler
était un type bien qui lui trouvait des
des bons côtés et c'est vrai qu'il
bénéficie d'une sorte d'immunité
d'impunité parce que c'est tellement un
grand artiste que les gens acceptent
n'importe quoi de lui y compris
l'antisémitisme qui est dégueulasse et
qui relate dans ses chansons et il on le
voit en train de danser avec Chris Brown
comme ça sur ses paroles précises en
disant j'ai couché avec une femme juste
ça lu a quand même ça lui a quand même
cûé le le mariage son mariage avec Kim
Kardashian et puis son contrat avec
Adidas il était milliardaire il a perdu
des centaines de millions d'euros il
avait plus que 100 millions d'euros 100
millions d' il reste combien mer 100
millions va B tu vas voir ave a avec 100
bûches
100 millions faut faire gaffe he 100
millions faut faire 100 millions faut
faire gaffe non mais je lui donne un
conseil à à Kenny West là le gars de
Dubaï euh merci mirriam palumba merci
d'avoir été là tu peux revenir quand tu
veux tu es toujours la bienvenue